foreign
let's go to Sarah in Joshua Texas what's
up Sarah
hi Dr John deloney what a pleasure what
a pleasure it is
my favorite podcast and also mortifying
yeah it's all good what's up
uh so I since I was six years old I have
what I didn't know was a disorder until
I was 15. uh a skin picking Disorder so
my my fingertips
are just always kind of cut and bloody
and
then it you know when I was 15 I started
pulling my hair out and there's names
for these things
oh my gosh you know the name hey uh do
you okay we're gonna we're already here
so we're gonna keep going do you
um when you pull out like eyelashes or
hair do you eat it
no I don't and I have heard of that but
no that's not me okay all right all
right
um
wow so why six
that is just a memory that's me
remembering the first time I was ever
bothering with my hands and I remember
being scolded for it too my my dad he he
would always tell me you know quit doing
that that's a habit
it's not a habit it is a
compulsion that's very very different
and people people don't understand that
they think it's just something that you
do because you do it it's it no it is
it's very purposeful it's not mindless
and it's excruciating it's it's
exhausting yes and you know I'm 31 now
it's been my whole life yes
um
how would you define a compulsion
when you
cannot refrain
okay
does that make sense yes
that's so strange it's strange because I
am a very controlled person I don't have
I don't have any vices I don't have
addictions I've never gotten caught up
with things that all of my friends did
you know I never got caught up in
alcohol cigarettes drugs like nothing
literally nothing maybe if you'd had a
few drinks I'm just kidding
um so that actually doesn't surprise me
at all
okay the
so do you promise that that you like
that you know I'm not I'm I'm uh I'm on
your side
I can believe that okay
um okay so let's do this first so you
can take
uh we'll geek out for just eight seconds
you can take like a past digging
approach like a cycling a little
psychoanalytic approach like what
happened in your past what what things
are being repressed what things happened
that led to this Behavior you can do
that and you can also take a very strict
behavioral approach okay
um that this is this is
um it's it's a it's a it's a learned
habit just a habit and then it just
ingrained itself and the Habit
ultimately becomes a compulsion
there's been some recent studies
um that suggest that it could also be
very biological in nature
like this is a brain
on a loop trying to solve some things
for itself or there's a serotonogenic
issues or there's all kinds of of
neurotransmitter neuromodulator issues
here's what I'm telling you that
I don't want you spending so much energy
a asking what's wrong with you
why are you broken
two you've probably spent a fair amount
of time
playing Indiana Jones with your past
trying to figure this out is that fair
um I wrote it down last week
literally trying to find a trigger or a
pattern or something
I'm and what you said you said Loop I'm
a
I wouldn't say that I'm a a person of
high anxiety but I'm very cyclic I
I will just run around in circles in my
brain until I find correct the root of
the issue and I don't know I don't know
maybe that does Define me as high
anxiety but I don't I don't know I don't
I was recently having a conversation
with a good buddy of mine who's a
psychologist at Brown University uh at
the in the in the research hospital
and I have a theory that I'm just
working through and I asked him like I
was like hey I need to talk through this
with you because as I read more nerd
literature
um the scientific studies
I I'm coming to believe and I have
nothing to back this up okay so this is
me just spitballing with my buddy uh but
he did say man I think you are dead on
to something and in fact he told me a
bunch of other studies I didn't know
existed
um some out of Kansas some out of a
couple other places that um would would
suggest that
I the way we are trained is that OCD
that basically life happens to you and
based off of your genetics some people
get dragged down into depression other
people get spun up into anxiety but that
it's a body reacting to stimulus it it
can't it's exceeding its capacity to to
deal with it and a derivative of anxiety
is OCD
I have been really
um
Blown Away by some of the the
neuroimaging around OCD
to the point that I am beginning to
wonder and Alan short did some great
work here
I think the root is OCD and depression
and anxiety and all of these other
Downstream things that we try to do is
our bodies trying to stop the loop
and you are a person of high control
who has been told since you were a
little girl that the way you control
things is gross and disgusting quit and
they may have loved you and been
incredible and wonderful
but sometimes depending on what kind of
brain you were born with and genetics
you were born with and experiences you
had
it may just take a splinter a crack in
the way you respond is wrong and who you
are is wrong
and your body says we've got to solve
for that and it gets anxious about it
and then it becomes a loop that gets
etched into concrete so I would my
challenge to you is a compulsion is a
habit on steroids
I think trying to differentiate between
the two of them uh is uh is a waste of
time and energy
your body has tried to figure out a way
to make you feel better and this is the
way it's chosen do you wish it was
something else for sure
um but this is what you got and so
here's why I tell you all visible or
obvious because I think I can hide I
can't I can't I can't hide this that's
right that's right
but here's the thing
you can't hate your body into healing
and you have been at war with Sarah
since you were six years old right
yes absolutely you've got to make peace
with Sarah
and the moment you can and literally
it's a moment the moment you can begin
to I mean you've probably heard of uh
ACT therapy act like acceptance and
commitment
you have to switch from war to curiosity
that's your only path forward
because every time you pull your hair
out you get pissed and you think you
screwed up something or you think what
are you doing why are you doing oh my
gosh
it's the worst it's the worst and people
who struggle with binge eating people
who struggle I mean it's these
compulsions people who smoke who grab
cigarettes who just sit in their
bathroom and have imaginary wars with
other people and it's like I can't stop
fighting somebody in my head and then I
see them at work and my body's like
there they are kill them and they're so
kind they're offering me a drink right
like it's like it's these habits these
Loops that become compulsions that we
lose control of
and the key back to control is curiosity
huh
what's my body trying to protect me from
and I'm saying it with a smile on my
face
what is my body trying to solve right
now
because it is pulling hair out of itself
and I'm also you see I'm I'm putting
some gaps between you
and what's happening
you are not your trick to a Mania you're
not a lunatic you're not crazy you're
not disgusting you're not gross
your body's figured out a way to solve a
thing
and it's just the solution isn't very
helpful
or actually I would bet you it's really
really really helpful or it wouldn't
keep doing it
but it's helpful that also doesn't make
sense it doesn't
it makes me feel worse
but does it shift your focus away from
what you can't control
oh absolutely does it shift your focus
away from the battles that are you are
raging on a daily basis that you can't
fix or change
well sometimes it's just I'm just trying
to work like I can't even be at work I
you know I work I work at a desk and I
actually work remote at work at home so
I'm just trying to be productive and
it's the only way I can describe it is
like someone's tapping on the back of
your head oh yeah and you and you are
you know twidding away and you try to
make it stop and they still tapping on
the back of your head until you give
your attention to that and then the
whole day goes by I haven't been as
productive as I want to and that's only
one example I have children like
sometimes I I can't be present in
anywhere else in my life because my
fingertips are bothering me that's so
absurd my eyelashes are bothering me who
feels their eyelashes like I'm not even
supposed to notice those things
says who
oh I I guess just general sane people
you've constructed a whole planet
about how terrible Sarah is and she's
not she's not
she's not
I will admit the things that you
struggle with are hard because they're
they're they are outside the norm they
don't happen to a lot of people although
I think the number I saw was 10 million
or 8 million people I mean so it's not
an insignificant number of people who
struggle with this but it is weird if
you're sitting there and you're
picking at your finger until it's
bleeding and you're pulling a piece of
hair out the back of your head and
you're doing it mindlessly while you're
watching TV and you look over and your
little son is our daughter staring at
you like what is that yeah that's
unnerving that's weird right it is
but you have create a constructed a
character around this of a lunatic unfit
to be a parent shouldn't be even in an
office with people
and you've created a whole person and
you hate that person
foreign
[Music]
I see that
let's try this
and at the root of that I think this is
and again so some of the neurological
stuff can be grooming habits that are
wired into us
that are just a little bit off the rails
okay and so it might be something as
simple as man I I need to take an SSRI
and have you tried that before
no I'm I'm actually not even familiar I
I
um I went to a therapist one time when I
was 15. I was prescribed antidepressants
tried that for about a week then I
refused them and never went back to a
professional ever again there is some um
there is some evidence that suggests
um ssris it's it's not
um benzodiazepines but it's it's ssris
that help with anxiety they're
anti-anxiety things but what here's what
here's the way I characterize them they
just turn the alarms down
so that I can go do the work that I
gotta do
so for instance
when I was sorry go ahead buried in
anxiety
I was sat at my table I met with my
buddy who's a medical doctor again I'm
super privileged to have a close friend
who I love and Trust that's a medical
doctor I get that but um I sat with him
for a long time and he said hey man I
don't see a path out of this for you
without some really good counseling and
some behavior modification and you can't
you're not in a place to do that
I sat at my table with a low level SSRI
that I cut in half okay so the lowest
dose and I cut that in half
and I wept because I thought I was a
failure
I thought I was a total loser
I had a new baby my son was like one
years old and I thought I was a such a
failure
and I wouldn't put a pill in my mouth
until I had a plan off of it my doctor
was like super helpful in making that
plan that plan was not even close to
reality but he humored me on it and um
here's all it did it did not solve my
anxiety it didn't solve my control
issues it didn't solve my loneliness it
didn't solve all these things
it didn't make me less uh um addiction
prone it didn't make any of that stuff
go away
what it did was it turned the Alarm
Systems way down
so that when I felt a compulsion to do
something I could
be curious about it
that tapping you feel it would make it
more like a like a like a whisper or a
breath instead of a A bamming in the
back of your head this is just me this
is me hypothesis like I'm just I'm not
saying you need to go get meds I'm
saying here's what it did for me and
what I want what I'm trying to get you
to do is to open up it may be time to
sit down and say okay what I've done to
this far it hasn't worked cool my body's
still getting what it needs from me by
doing this
um I want to stop this Behavior so let's
try another Avenue that may be
medication that may be hypnosis that may
mean be EMDR that may be several other
avenues but let's give this a shot does
that make sense
yes what I don't want you to do is to
give in to Despair and quit and think
you're screwed up and broken
because here's why you start to turn
from your kids
Fair
yeah and you create space between your
kids are you married
no
okay
you create space between romantic
partners and they think it's their fault
is that fair
yeah I could see that
oh actually I could definitely see that
I'm I'm so I'm so afraid of yeah
medicated yeah I get that I get that
I'm afraid if I
if I take something that numbs the
alarms what else is it going to numb
this process that's absolutely Fair
and there's certain drugs that um I
wouldn't I have written into my
um
psychiatric power of attorney that I
won't have in my body because they turn
joy and paying off at the same switch
right and so that's terrifying yeah it
is it is and also
um
I can just tell you my experience
um I am somebody who does not advocate
for medication and it was a powerful
um tool in my tool kit when I was
getting well
and I haven't been on it in years years
and years and years
but for a season man it was powerful
and again that might not be your journey
what you need to do is figure out ways
you can make peace with Sarah because
you can't Over Control Sarah because
this whole thing is a control response
or maybe a biological thing which then
you're going to need medication as
though you have a heart like and just be
grateful that you live in this one with
a weird sliver of time and we have all
of this you know incredible technology
all right
but all of this here's all this is
making peace with Sarah
will you do me just of all the favors
I'm asking one I think you should go
talk to somebody not because you're
broken but but because like you have
tried to fix the plumbing under your
house
and you're like I don't know how to do
what's next that's it you just got a
professional is gonna have different
skills you're not screwed up you're not
broken you're not ah you just don't have
the skill set there that's great that's
awesome you have tried and you'd be like
all right I need someone with different
skills luckily there's people who went
to college for a long time to learn how
those skills that can help okay
that's number one
underneath that number two is
I want you to keep a journal
and I want you to begin to write five
things a day
that you are that you love about Sarah
okay you actually never
I I could have I would have bet my car
on that my car is not nice that would
have been a great big bet but
um you you strike me as such a loving
caring person and
that love and care is wrapped over like
like
um wrapping paper over
a nuclear
bombs worth of energy
grasping for control
and at some point we have to release the
tension that is held underneath that
thing and for most people in that
situation
that feels like the end of their life
because if I let this thing unwind this
thing I'm controlling and compressing
and holding on to it's all of my mind if
I let it go everything spins into chaos
in the most terrifying thing is chaos
and so when I start to feel chaos and I
start to feel something I can't control
like my kids Behavior like my husband
walking out on me like climate change
like whatever else you think is coming
the economy is all coming down or
they're gonna elect a Democrat no or
whatever
your body then has some built-in
mechanisms to divert your attention from
that stuff that we can't control to this
and it's cool man body's just trying to
take care of you trying to love you
that's assuming again this isn't
biological in nature right but
sitting with somebody that can help you
slowly peel the thing apart let that
thing some of the tension of the energy
release
that's the path to Healing my friend
I'm so so grateful for you sir you're a
brave brave woman and you're an
incredible mom
starting today we're gonna start making
friends with Sarah we're gonna come to
love Sarah and Sarah's gonna become
somebody worth taking care of and loving
they're gonna be curious man why is my
body doing that
and that's going to be where we start
getting well